en los mamíferos la percepción del olor
implica las interacciones de las
moléculas de olor en el aire del entorno
con las proteínas receptoras en las
neuronas olfativas en la cavidad nasal
la unión de moléculas de olor con las
proteínas receptoras desencadena
potenciales de acción en las neuronas
olfativas y resulta en la transmisión de
la información al cerebro los genomas de
los mamíferos típicamente tienen
alrededor de 1000 genes receptores
olfatorios funcionales cada uno codifica
para un receptor de olor único inciso a
describe cómo se transmite la señal a
través de la sinapsis de una neurona
sensorial olfativa activa a la interna
eurona que transmite la información al
cerebro muy bien este es el inciso y
permítanme dibujar la neurona sensorial
olfativa activa estas son sus dendritas
y este es su acción y estas son las
terminales de la acción y podría dibujar
otros detalles pero no creo que necesite
es dibujar todos estos detalles en el
examen pero solo para tener una idea de
las cosas también podríamos dibujar el
núcleo justo aquí así que esta es la
neurona sensorial olfativa activa
neurona sensorial
volve activa
activa y permítanme dibujar a la interna
eurona voy a dibujar una de sus
dendritas esta es la interna eurona con
sus dendritas
y su acción
y de ahí va al cerebro
y si hacemos un acercamiento a la
sinapsis donde se transmite la señal
entre los dos
hacemos un acercamiento justo aquí
veríamos la terminal del axón de la
neurona sensorial tal vez se ve algo así
y luego tenemos la interneuronas por
aquí y esta es la sinapsis este es un
acercamiento a la sinapsis y la neurona
sensorial olfativa activa tenemos este
potencial de acción que va a ir viajando
a lo largo del axón de la neurona
sensorial olfativa activa y luego cuando
llega a la terminal de la acción va a
detonar la liberación de
neurotransmisores por lo que los
neurotransmisores típicamente se
encuentran en estas vesículas pero luego
cuando llega el potencial de acción son
liberados en el espacio sináptica y la
interneuronas tiene proteínas que
perciben a los neurotransmisores y eso
activa la neurona así que una vez más
esta es la interna eurona y podríamos
decir que
la interneuronas
activada
de hecho también podría ser inhibida
los
neurotransmisores
liberados
en la sinapsis
por la neurona
sensorial
de vida
al potencial
de axxion
y probablemente esto es suficiente mejor
sea un poco más con este dibujo y
podrías dibujar otros detalles
podrías dibujar la vaina de mielina
también podríamos dibujar el núcleo pero
la idea básica es que la señal va de una
neurona a otra con la liberación de
estos neurotransmisores los cuales son
moléculas bastante pequeñas que activan
a la siguiente neurona y después de que
esa señal ocurre son metabolizados por
enzimas puede haber algunos que siempre
se mantengan en el entorno pero lo
importante es que mandan una señal de
una neurona a otra y podrían activar la
siguiente neurona o podrían inhibir la
pero en este caso probablemente la
activan muy bien vamos a hacer el inciso
b
explica como la expresión de un número
limitado de genes receptores olfatorios
como puedes ver hay 1000 puede dar lugar
a la percepción de miles de dólares
utiliza la evidencia acerca de la
cantidad de genes receptores olfatorios
para apoyar tu respuesta una manera de
pensar en ello y esta es una teoría es
que no necesariamente se tiene una
relación 1 a 1 entre los receptores
olfatorios y las moléculas de olor
no necesariamente
se tiene
una relación
uno a uno
entre las moléculas
de olor
y
las proteínas
receptoras
tal vez
una proteína dada
puede detectar
varias moléculas
y viceversa
esto podría
dar lugar
aquí
y muchas combinaciones
puedan
y ser detectadas
así que a pesar de que podríamos tener
tal vez estos mil genes olfatorios que
codifican para 1000 proteínas receptoras
podrías pensar que eso lo vas a poder
detectar 1000 moléculas diferentes pues
no cada una de ellas puede detectar más
de una molécula y cuando vienen en
combinaciones diferentes podrían activar
el cerebro de maneras diferentes voy a
añadir esto la respuesta esto podría dar
lugar a que muchas combinaciones puedan
ser detectadas y diferentes olores
puedan ser percibidos
x
el cerebro
existe una posibilidad de que cada uno
de estos genes puede codificar proteínas
de diferentes maneras pero nos dicen que
cada una codifica para un receptor de
olor único por lo que me parece que esta
es una buena respuesta que no
necesariamente se tiene una relación 1 a
1 entre las moléculas de olor y las
proteínas receptoras
tal vez una proteína dada puede detectar
varias moléculas o una molécula podría
ser detectada por varios receptores y
las diferentes combinaciones de todo lo
anterior significa que podríamos
detectar mucho más que mil moléculas
especialmente moléculas diferentes en
combinaciones diferentes podríamos
detectar miles y miles de entre comillas
olores